Bonjour Armelle pour aller plus loin
dans quelques heures donc il y aura
cette cette rencontre américain se sont
déjà parlé on a évidemment l'échelle de
diplomatie qui se sont retrouvés
récemment à Stockholm c'est la première
fois que les chefs d'État vont se se
parler franchement qu'est-ce qu'il faut
attendre de ce rendez-vous on a l'air de
dire pas grand-chose vous avez
certainement tu dors pas grand-chose
simplement il se parle l'enjeu et en
fait de dire s'ils s'entendent assez
bien sur ce sommet virtuel on pourrait
imaginer que on est en présentiel au
printemps et s'il y a une rencontre
direct dans ces cas-là ce sera peut-être
plus porter la vous avez raison de
rappeler le Canada et Isabelle c'est que
quand les chef de la diplomatie se sont
rencontrés sais bien qu'il préparer ce
sommet virtuel et qu'en fait les
Américains essaient de jouer toutes les
cartes pour avertir justement de cette
escalade il y a même le directeur de la
CIA qui est parti en Europe du côté de
l'Ukraine donc on a vraiment cette
inquiétude la du côté des Américains qui
disent trop de trucs ma c'est trop de
volonté de la part de Poutine
certainement de faire un dérapage dans
la région du Donbass du côté de
l'Ukraine est cette inquiétude qui en
ressort se soumit virtuel ça sert aussi
quand même à ça a passé dans la
désescalade mais est-ce que justement je
bâille donne va jouer sur les sanctions
sanctions économiques il a déjà imposé
est-ce qu'il va aller un petit peu plus
loin avec tout le système swift derrière
qui se donnera une fusion de la Russie
sur ce système interbancaire les
dérangerait davantage parce que
évidemment du côté des Russes on alarme
toujours du gaz qui achemine qui est à
Chemillé en Europe est-ce que vous êtes
en train de dire take en coulisse on est
effectivement assez inquiet de
l'attitude des uns et des et des autres
ce niveau de tension ça faisait
longtemps qu'on avait pas assister à
cela malheureusement oui parce qu'on a
bien dû tension au travers de la planète
et on n'avait pas besoin d'avoir ça au
cœur de l'Europe on voit bien
effectivement que le président ukrainien
Céline ce qui est très inquiet lui aussi
du coup son sa façon de répondre c'est
que il s'arme il achète américain et là
j'ai des armes des Américains il a
acheté les armes en turc des drones ça
ça énerve est Vladimir Poutine et donc à
tout moment il peut y avoir le pas de
trop qui fait d'un côté ou de l'autre
peut-être pas du côté des Russes qui
savent quand on est très bien quand
est-ce qu'il faut manœuvrer ou quand
est-ce qu'il faut s'arrêter exetera mais
si par hasard on a une explosion du côté
du crânien là on aura de toute manière
les Russes qui rentreront bille en tête
sur ce qui est en train de se passer et
derrière on sait pas comment vous allez
les Européens et les Américains donc
aujourd'hui tous les systèmes de
renseignements sont très observateur de
ce qui se passe dans la zone en se
rappelant effectivement qu'il faut
négocier avec discernement vis-à-vis des
Russes qui connaissent parfaitement les
les stratégies pour faire avancer
l'adversaire vers là où ils veulent mais
en sachant aussi avoir du discernement
vis-à-vis des Américains qui ont parfois
su gonfler les événements quand il le
fallait on a forcément en tête l'Irak
par exemple merci beaucoup Armelle pour
le décryptage évidemment on sera ce que
donne cet entretien par visioconférence
en fin d'après-midi